[Music]
barbara's with us in minneapolis hey
barbara welcome to the ramsay show
hey papa dave and ken great to talk with
you guys thank you for all that you're
doing you too my husband and i have been
married for 10 years we have a blended
family with children ranging from the
ages of 32 down to 21.
uh there is a 21 year excuse me a 26
year old son my stepson my husband's son
uh married lives in wisconsin has five
children under the age of seven
so they're busy
um
this son has asked us over two years ago
bar asked to borrow three thousand
dollars um my husband and i we are baby
steppers we're on baby step six
and hopefully we'll be seeing in about a
year and a half for our final debt free
screen to move us to baby step seven
um we've had a difficult time getting
the son and daughter-in-law to pay us
back and it is causing significant
strife in the family
my husband and i are to the point where
we just know we're not going to see the
money again the remaining balance of
1500 and we've accepted that and we've
moved on
um however the sun continues to just
give daggers and say that you know
we were he was entitled to the money he
deserved the money and our other adult
children see this and hear these
comments
and where i would really love your
experience ken is
the son
does not work he is not supporting his
family and then throws the emotional
manipulation to my husband and i
that we will be the ones responsible
when him and our grandchildren get
kicked out on the streets
so we're trying to determine how we just
allow these these arrows to bounce off
of us while holding the empty bag of a
financial loan
um which caused a strike between my
husband and i because i did not want to
borrow the money so we've had to
solidify you borrowed the money to give
him
i'm saying you borrowed the money to
give him
we borrowed the money that's a double
deal oh my gosh not only did he not pay
you back but you went into debt to do
this oh ouch ouch no we didn't no we did
not go into debt no we're we're in baby
steps oh you loaned him the money you
didn't borrow
him the money
no well exactly you don't get you don't
get to tell him what to do
no your bank his bank doesn't get to
tell him what to do
right
so any guidance on how we just you know
don't engage in this toxicity while
you're trying as well
his dad needs to call him up and say the
loan is forgiven
forget it just forget it
we don't we're not going to loan you any
money anymore ever again
but this loan's forgiven you don't know
me anymore
and i love you
i don't agree with a lot of things
you're doing but you're a grown man and
you're allowed to do those things
and um we're still gonna be friends
i'm still gonna be grandpa
and you don't owe us any more money
forget it
and if you if you want some help
uh we can give you some coaching and
we'll be your biggest cheerleaders
but we won't give you either one
coaching or cheering
without your permission
cut him loose
set him free
he is
this is bothering you
way more than it's bothering him
oh yeah you've had 28 million dollars
worth of grief he's had 20 cents worth
of grief
he hadn't got enough he had enough
character for this to bother him
well exactly yeah
so this is both barbara barbara
let it go
it's just fifteen hundred dollars
no absolutely and what what breaks my
heart more than my pocketbook because we
don't need that much you can't make
your heart broken heart didn't even
matter to him
well right but it hurts my heart how he
speaks to my husband his father
that's your husband needs to say you
can't speak to me that way anymore
yeah
okay you can only speak to me in in
tones that are reasonable i don't allow
anyone family or otherwise to speak to
me in
you know unpleasant ways in an ongoing
and ongoing process now somebody can
have a moment that's one thing okay
um i don't cut everybody out of my life
that has a moment that's not what i'm
talking about but but as an ongoing
abusive thing
that's you know you're welcome to call
here and you're welcome to be in our
home but you're gonna maintain these
levels of volume and this level of
reasonable respect and i'm going to give
you the same thing
but you know don't call here and
we're not responsible for your children
they're your children
correct we love you
and what we're cheering for you if you
ever want any advice on how to get where
we are financially we can show you
but but but we're not going to tell you
what to do and you're not going to make
us give you our money
you're a confused young man
and he just needs some boundaries
your husband is a nice gentle man isn't
he
yes
he's a six foot four giant with a big
heart and a very very soft gentle
personality
so i want your husband to roar just a
little bit
and you do too yeah and you do too
now i don't want him to be mean i don't
want to be mean but it takes strength to
set boundaries
and that's what's lacking here is
boundaries and let me tell you anytime
you're someone like your your your
stepson who doesn't respect boundaries
anytime you put up a fence and he's used
to playing in your yard he's going to
have a fit
so don't expect this to go well
it's not going to go well because this
kid's a twerp
yep okay and so all you can do is just
say you have to sit over there in your
yard and have your little fit you can't
sit in my yard and have a fit
and i just don't worry about the money
money's off the table
money's off the table and the fact that
you forgive it is not going to make this
young man suddenly have character
yeah and i think that's also one of the
hardest things for my husband too
exactly
that's amazing
it's sailed that ship sailed
this is this kid's way too old for you
to fix him
you just gotta love him where he is and
if he wants some help i can show him how
you can show him how
but until he's ready for some help it's
everybody else's fault
and bart i would just add you need to
encourage your husband that this is not
a direct reflection on him it's very
heartbreaking when you see a kid and a
grown man make these kind of decisions
and say the things that he's saying but
i'll tell you this i i want parents to
hear this
is it's really hard when you see adult
kids do things that you didn't model for
them you didn't teach them how to do it
uh but when you see an adult kid like
this who's not working to support his
family um there's other stuff going on
there's way more going on he's not lazy
even though he presents as lazy he's
lost and you said it earlier he said
this is a confused young man and i think
you're right confusion
can make a person so lost that they lose
all gumption to get out there and do
something and that's the best your
husband could be aware of to try to love
his son that way but i agree dave you
got to cut it off for a while until he
gets away from call do not loan
money do not loan money
to your kids
if you want to give them money give them
money never loan them money because you
change the relationship and that's part
of what's soured this relationship